He wants to get over 9000 comments
of your YouTube videos.
He receives the same number of comments
for every clip with cats that uploads,
and the same number of comments
for every clip with dogs that uploads.
This is unbelievable in a sense.
Totally the same number of comments for each clip with cats
and totally the same number for each clip with dogs.
But we will just accept what we have been told.
The following inequality
By showing the number of clips with cats,
and D presents the number of clips with dogs,
which Goku has to upload,
to achieve its goal.
So, 750 in the number of clips with cats
plus 450 on the number of clips with dogs
must be greater than 9000.
According to inequality,
how many reviews each cat gets with cats
and how many comments does each dog get with a dog?
Let's see if we understand what we have here
in this inequality, to answer the question.
He wants to get over 9,000 comments,
as we see it here.
He wants more than 9,000 comments.
We can see this as a number of comments,
which he actually receives.
Since we have some number of C,
we can assume that C ...
We know that C is the number of clips with cats.
So we have the number of C,
this is the number of comments,
which he gets from the clips of cats.
For a Clip with Cats
he will get 750 comments.
Because, if I say, "Hey, look.
I have Cs of videos with cats and for each of them
I have exactly 750 comments. "
So I will have 750 on the C comment
total for all my cat clips.
Each video with cats will receive 750 comments.
And in a similar way
every clip with dogs gets ...
This is the total number of comments on the videos with dogs.
You collect all these together.
We see the total number of comments needed
be greater than 9000.
Okay if the total number of videos with dogs is D,
then we see that he gets 450 comments on a clip with dogs.
450 comments per video on the number of clips with dogs
gives us the total number of comments from clips with dogs.
So he gets 450 comments for a dog clip.
Can Goku achieve his goal by uploading 8 clips of cats
and 7 clips with dogs?
Let's think about it.
8 clips with cats and 7 clips with dogs.
Let's see.
If we have 750, let me write them in the same colors,
if we have 750 by 8,
plus 450 at 7,
is that greater than ...
I will write a question mark because we do not know.
Is this greater than 9000?
Okay, we just have to calculate it.
How much will it be?
Let's see.
700 at 8 is 5600.
This will be 5600,
plus another 50 at 8 is 400.
5600 plus 400 is 60 hundred or 6000.
That's 6000 here.
If there are 8 clips with cats,
he gets 750 comments per clip,
so there will be a total of 6000 comments
for all 8 clips with cats.
And then 450 at 7,
let's see, 400 at 7 is 2800,
plus another 350,
this will be how much?
3150, is it?
Let's see, this will be,
let me show you that this is so,
2800 plus ...
400 at 7 is 2800.
50 at 7 is 350.
Yes, I think this is true.
That's all, 3150.
The 6000 Plus 3150 is really bigger than 9000.
It's really bigger than 9,000.
This is 9150,
which is really bigger than 9,000.
So yes, he can achieve his goal,
uploading 8 clips with cats and 7 clips with dogs.